[Musique]
quand même vous aimiez la littérature et
vous avez approché de grands écrivains
français c'est un c'était vrai ça c'est
autre chose peut-être que vous avez raté
votre vie de ce côté là parce que vous
êtes un vétéran celle de gens qui ont
réussi mais vous êtes un artiste qui n'a
pas su faire son chemin où je suis je
suis pas un artiste plasticien raté je
ne suis pas un artiste rappelez vous je
suis un artiste manque au sens premier
du terme c'est à dire je ne suis pas
passé à la crêperie
mais vous en j'aime d'un coup on verra
j'aurais peut-être pu je pourrais
peut-être même et j'aime beaucoup
regarder l'acte et j'aime beaucoup
contempler l'artiste j'aime les faiseurs
de ce sens un bel bien des sternes
j'aime approcher les gens qui créent
quelques manières que ce soit et vous
avez ignoré de coquetterie dans ce que
je vais dire vous c'est vrai que j'ai
fait beaucoup de choses et il accomplit
une certaine réussite comme on dit nous
et jacques chancel je serais beaucoup
plus fiable a écrit une cette tâche de
flaubert bien berger artiste je veux
bien mais quel artiste auriez vous été
émis une manière de se dire artistes de
se faire artistes où il faut pas se dire
artistes d'abord infolettre de nous
écouter moi j'ai patrouillé très
longtemps sur les frontières de
l'écriture et j'ai évidemment failli
franchir ce pas et puis je n'ai pas fait
alors si j'avais dû être un artiste
j'aurais probablement être un écrivain
[Musique]